[Music]
hey folks Chris waters here with
GameSpot on the show floor at e3 2014
I'm in the Ubisoft booth about to talk
to mark Thompson the narrative director
of far cry 4 about the game which has
had a fantastic showing so far at e3
mark it's been a big big one for you
guys yeah I think I mean we obviously
weren't a surprise white people were
expecting us we'd already been announced
but I think the fact that we showed up
with so much playable content and people
could get their hands on and fall into
kyrat and start playing around with the
open world has really got people excited
which is cool and I am one of those
people let's talk for a second about
your ambitions for farcry 4 farcry 3 was
a big game with so much to do and so
much it was so good how do you guys what
are you hoping to build how are you
building on that for far cry 4 where do
you want to take this series yeah I mean
so when we when we ship far cry 3
honestly the the open-world and its
appeal was a surprise it caught us by
surprise as it as a development team
because when you develop the game you're
so close to it and you don't often times
you don't realize and uh and the in the
end after we shipped we found out that
players were spending just as much time
if not a little bit more time than in
story missions they were in the
open-world so it was a almost a 50/50
experience but it really wasn't
developed with that kind of focus the
open world kind of crept along quietly
and then surprised us at the end
so for Far Cry 4 it was really more of a
shift in philosophy to be focusing you
know equal efforts on the story and the
missions and developing that open-world
and all of the systems and you know the
players stories that can be generated by
just playing and exploring the
open-world let's talk about that
open-world for a second in kirat it's a
mountainous region so you guys have a
whole different verticality to deal with
you've got a whole different geography
than the tropical islands of Far Cry 3
so what kind of new opportunities does
that bring for you in terms of design as
a designer it's really uh it's really
liberating to have kind of an extra
layer of verticality right so with the
mountains we obviously have incredible
height differences between peaks and
valleys and
gives us new gameplay opportunities so
when we started prototyping the world we
just saw how just how much elevation we
had we quickly realized that not all of
the navigation mechanics from Far Cry 3
we're going to cut it for that
environment so we started to add some
new things so we brought in the
grappling system so now you can you can
climb on grappling points and jump
between grab it so it's very very fluid
and dynamic system it interacts with all
of the other systems from Far Cry 3 so
mid grapple you can jump off open the
wingsuit and then transition to a
parachute and if you can see another
grapple point you can hit that as well
and one seamless transition which is
really cool and we only we have the the
gyrocopter as well which is a new
flyable a new flyable vehicle so you can
i mean it's it's intended that you can
get from low points to high points
quickly but i've been seeing on the show
floor just as many people have been
using it to a fly and rain down death
from above over outposts
I believe that immediately the wingsuit
was one of my favorite things and I'm
really intrigued about this gyrocopter
specifically how you guys showed it off
during the press conference with the
cooperative play having one player
flying it the other player like maybe
riding maybe jumping off and and sort of
causing that that dual mayhem the
cooperative play must just you know take
those sort of emergent players stories
that can happen in an open world and
just multiply them exponentially yeah I
mean that was the whole idea it was just
adding this extra variable it's like
more more controllable chaos and its
really the whole idea behind coop was
that you could call in a friend to your
open world and then you together could
go on your own like mini mini adventure
create your own story attack an outpost
liberate a bell tower go and do some
hunting find some materials and what's
good is when your friend leaves you keep
all of the progression so if you take
over four or five outpost in a session
with a friend when he leaves you still
keep that in your single-player
experience excellent and we are getting
some noise here because people are
talking about Far Cry 4 here this is the
magic of being on the show floor at e3
so uh we're gonna wrap up soon but I
can't let you go here without talking
about another conveyance that you guys
introduced during the demo and that's
the elephants yeah I mean I think the
elephant has been honestly we knew we
had something cool with the elephant but
again it's caught us by surprise just
how excited people are by the prospect
of the elephant
think the fact that it's hard vehicle
part weapon and it's just it's
generating so many more player stories
than we thought it would be it's a it's
great to see just how excited people get
when they get hands-on with that
elephant it must be pretty excited yet
to see people trying it out and using
this stuff in new ways that you guys
didn't even plan for I I'm sure you've
got some more stuff to announce in the
coming months before the game comes out
that we can all look forward to but when
can I actually get my hands in there
grappled to an elephant fly across the
chasm in my wingsuit in Far Cry 4 it's
going to be on November 18th this year
is going to be on a ps3 ps4 Xbox 360
Xbox one and on PC mark thank you so
much for your time here at e3 2014
that's far cry 4 folks one to watch you
and I
- shut up
[Music]
should I stay or should I go
[Music]